[Musique]
au Salvador c'est devenu un acte de
bravoure protesté contre les abus du
gouvernement de Nayet bauquelin le pays
vit depuis le 27 mars sous état
d'exception la police peut arrêter toute
personne considérée suspecte sans
enquête préliminaire la fille de Santos
est emprisonnée depuis 7 mois
la compagnie qui allait ouvrir un compte
en banque pour la police a procédé à un
contrôle d'identité vous n'avez pas ses
papiers sur elle
aura apporté une pièce d'identité on lui
a dit que ma fille était en état
d'arrestation
ma fille s'appelle Carla mairie are
mundo elle a 22 ans
dans un pays où le gouvernement a peu à
peu miner tout opposition les familles
des victimes ont un dernier espoir
l'église
nous vous demandons audience de la part
du mouvement des victimes du régime mon
Seigneur à Las
dans la cathédrale l'archevêque fera
finalement la sourde oreille et fera ses
annonces hebdomadaires sans fermentation
des manifestants à sa porte
oui on est très déçu par l'archevêque
mais on va continuer notre combat
depuis plus de 20 ans le Salvador vivait
dans la terreur celle des gangs qui
enlèvent extorquer assassine la
population le pays fut considéré pendant
plusieurs années le plus dangereux du
monde
ou le régime dans une famille de filles
ont été enlevées par les gangs et le
fils a été arrêté arbitrairement par le
régime de qui doit-on se défendre
d'insécurité que le président naïd
boukélé a juré d'éradiquer par la
méthode forte une main de fer qui lui
vaut un taux de popularité de plus de
85%
l'état d'exception c'est très bien
ça m'a fait de mal co délinquants
ne sortaient presque pas de chez eux à
cause de l'insécurité
le gouvernement vante la construction
d'un centre pénitentaire pouvant
accueillir plus de 40 000 détenus dans
les faits le nombre d'homicides à
drastiquement chuté mais n'ayez boukélé
verrouille peu à peu les mécanismes du
pouvoir juge de la Cour suprême limogée
annonce de sa candidature à sa propre
succession ce que la Constitution
interdit presse musée Juan ne quitte pas
ses valises depuis plusieurs mois nous
le rencontrons à Rio de Janeiro au
Brésil le président lui-même s'en est
pris à lui sur les réseaux sociaux
journalistes et anthropologue Juan
étudie depuis des années les gangs comme
phénomène social
c'est une des attaques du président
contre moi par Twitter
alors que Juan était en train d'enquêter
sur les liens entre un fonctionnaire du
gouvernement et le plus puissant gang du
pays les pressions passent de simples
tweets au harcèlement judiciaire
ils ont ouvert des poursuites à mon
encontre et je suis en ce moment
poursuivi pour clim organisé justement
aux gens qui étaient sur le procureur
général c'est une manière de nous
harceler avec acharnement jusqu'à ce
qu'on arrête de faire notre travail
reviendrait au Salvador avant la fin de
l'année pour reprendre ses enquêtes avec
plus d'un pour cent de la population
actuellement incarcérée le système pénal
est complètement saturé ephrain offre
une assistance juridique gratuite dans
ce cabinet ils sont deux avocats et
reçoivent entre 60 et 80 demande d'aide
par jour
nous avons deux conditions pour accepter
les dossiers
que la personne soit issue d'un milieu
pauvre
et que la personne emprisonnée n'est pas
appartenu à une structure criminelle
les commissariats de police ont des
objectifs quotidiens d'arrestation à
atteindre et les détentions arbitraires
pour remplir ses quotas touche souvent
les plus pauvres cette femme est sans
ressource depuis la détention de son
père et de son beau-frère il y a 5 mois
ce qui se passe en ce moment au Salvador
me fait très mal si seulement je pouvais
partir avec ma famille
ce n'est pas juste ce que l'on vit
ils ont détruit ma famille
ils ont généré une vraie terreur au sein
de la population
parce que beaucoup ont utilisé cet état
d'exception pour se venger par exemple
de problème de voisinage en allant
dénoncer n'importe qui pour appartenance
à un
gangs ils viennent et arrête la personne
sans plus d'explications
des audiences expéditives ou des
centaines de cas sont passés en revue le
même jour la croisade de Nailly boukélé
contre l'insécurité a fait passer le
Salvador de l'un des pays les plus
dangereux à l'un des plus sûrs du
continent mais au prix de dérive
autoritaires et de milliers d'innocents
en prison